on this episode I turn back the clock
and talk a lot of wine
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode one 60 of the ask
gary vee show nice rainy Tuesday we're
scoping on the periscope we continue to
bring in friends from the vaynermedia
family why don't you tell the Vayner
nation who you are and a little bit
about yourself my name is Melissa I'm an
associate copywriter and and you're from
Virginia very nice like Andy kay thanks
for being us ah this is a very special
episode because it's kind of collides my
two worlds this is a very much a wine
themed episode we have got reached out
to by some of the people on vaynermedia
on the west coast they're working on
some client stuff for a really cool new
show Steve actually you know even more
about it than I do
I'll rely on you in a little bit here
geez we've got it really in there this
is good
what like India gets a lot of this
attention right less less so me these
days I agree we need to change that now
that India's cut her hair you'll be
getting more of the attention all right
Steve won't you tell everybody a little
bit about what you know uncork is an
upcoming TV show on Esquire if you guys
are familiar with the Saw movies right
yes based on those so it's so the show
version of that movie that kind of hit
really strong right exactly so you saw
it I did yeah did you see it Jesus sorry
for the sorry for the massively visceral
reaction sorry that I offended you and
asked you if you watched a wine movie
you're scared of everything you don't
watch movies no Suns not scary
Sam was a wine movie no not saw man no
Somme got him did you see it's fun you
should want you need to get a little
more cultured up stuff on it can't just
be about basketball in hip hop good all
right so so what we have here I think
what I saw through the passage emails
was we have multiple people that are
starring in the show asking me video
class at all video questions how many do
we have six sexes possible all right
before we go into the questions we also
you and I work very closely on back to
the wine theme
a Skillshare of course once you see
let's get back into it oh hi there so if
you guys remember the old episodes of
Wine Library TV where Gary we do like
the mystery box taste along we teamed up
with Skillshare who's an amazing company
that does online continuing learning
courses we did an amazing course with
them for the last book is yes and we did
a wine tasting course with Gary that's
all about how to be a better wine taster
how to be a better wine buyer in time
for the holidays and so you can go over
this link I'll link it up look it up
alright let's get into the show by the
way the Jets are very hurt very hurt I'm
very worried about Thursday
all right good thanks they're just hurt
so everyone's hurt which was didn't from
Morton Harris
Morgan Harris all right Gary this is
what I want to know given that wine is
currently marketed relative to other
alcohols like beer liquors what if the
wine industry changed the conversation
to market wine as a food food culture is
huge right now
and what if we got people to think about
wine more is it food rather than just
another alcohol great question
Morgan Morgan Morgan great question uh I
think that's a really smart thought I
think you're barking up the right tree
in general in marketing and I'm gonna
try to make this show very valuable to
everybody that watches it and I know a
lot of you're not wine enthusiasts so
I'll go very business on it using
Morgan's main theme I'm a big believer
that you need to market things the value
prop of things differently and look for
white spaces they a bottled water
company you're always talking about
hydration and thirst and things of that
nature but maybe you start thinking
about it for like how water is powerful
for the brain
you gotta find white spaces that bring
value props to other products and so if
you start thinking about this like a
food product it might change the way
people think about it it's clearly a lot
more people eat food then drink wine so
I think it opens up the category I think
the problem is and I've thought about
this for 20 years I don't think you can
pull it off I don't think you can get
people to really understand that a
beverage is a food or thinking about it
you can make a ticket more seriously a
la Coffee a la wine you see what's going
on in brown spirits right now we can
make them you know think about wine in a
more complicated way and
more perplexed way the problem is that's
where I think wine is I think people
actually think about wine more carefully
than they think about food which is in
essence your point right if we can make
people less intimidated about it and
think of it as a more casual as a
standard within food I mean the way the
wine business wants you to think is that
this is always at the table when you're
eating because then you've created more
occasions to use the product and know
where you go so I think I think um I
think it's the right thought I think
it's a far-fetched dream to think that
you can get people to really think about
it in a way that it's mandatory to as
many use cases as we do with food which
is really the holy grail of that but the
interesting part of the question for
everybody here is whatever you sell
whatever services you have if you can
make them think about it in a way that
brings more value for example with
vaynermedia I make people realize that
our machine our process works for
anything not just selling stuff but
getting somebody elected right getting
donations from a non-profit like the
Machine can actually create any
awareness around anything that can
create a a business result or an end
result of your choice and so that's
everybody's job in here like how do you
get people to think about your products
in a different way this this used to be
something you wore right like it was it
was a functional item you had tennis
shoes unbranded and then over time
people came along and started branding
it and it went into a fashion statement
right and now it's a collector's item
there's a lot of sneakers being bought
to put on a shelf and then trade now
you've got the tennis sneaker in a 40
year window going from just being a
utility to play sports to or run or
what-have-you
to them being a fashion category play
and now a collector's category play
three sections hence why we sell a lot
more sneakers in society today than we
used to
that's a real life example what was good
I was happy with that all right come on
back to the punchline on that because I
want to make my final point cuz I didn't
see the whole thing through somebody had
to think in the 70's and 60s like wait a
minute these tennis shoes can be fashion
items like for example right now I'm
collecting all the like merchandise in'
and ancillary things around Facebook
to Graham and snapchat and putting them
away as collectibles because I think
they're going to be worth money because
I think that's pop culture so I think
like a snapchat pillow that they made
like three years ago right now is not
worth that much on eBay but I think
there's worth five hundred bucks
seventeen years from now you have to
project like the selfie stick
can there be a brand that's created
that's a beats by dre like thing for the
selfie stick that's how I'm projecting
got it so when I say the sneaker you may
think will I sell posters well what
other use cases can there be like you
got a project yeah
Yanik got some big guns hey Gary Vee
this is ionic bender in Somali a
University Club my question for you
today is if you could be a Somali at any
restaurant in New York City which one
would it be and why great question hey I
oh great great question
my choice would be Shake Shack I love
that thank you and here's the reason I
would take it very seriously
I would pair with the you know chicken
dogs and and the cheese burgers
obviously and all the other things the
and I would take it I would put out a
ton of content I would really push Danny
to like put the pairings on the menu for
the cheeseburger and a hot dogs and
different things of that nature the
chili you could do some incredible stuff
with that and the reason I'd want to do
that is because that's mass appeal my
passion for wine is to get as many
people to drink it as possible and a
place where I think I can move the
needle and bring people that are not in
our amazing world together and caring
about this product would be Shake Shack
at that scale there's a lot of locations
there's tons of asses on those seats on
an everyday basis and if I can get
people to realize that great wine can be
casual that would be very very powerful
and I think I could have a lot of fun
with it I tend to be reverent in the
wine space I think that brand is but
it's clearly premium fast food and I
think that's the right spot and so I
think a very serious wine program at
Shake Shack has enormous potential to
really change wine culture in New York
City and and the world and I think
that's very powerful and important and
that's what I would want to be
associated with you like that no thank
you
so my name is Jack Mason and the wine
director of marcha restaurant and my
question is what do you think the impact
of the recent news of Union Square
Hospitality moving away from tipping
will have on New York in general or the
industry as a whole this is a really
interesting conversation then the CEO of
resi and app I'm involved and had a
great discussion with some thought
leaders in the restaurant space around
this it's very fascinating my so I think
Danny is amazing and always innovating
and doing incredible things and I think
it's amazing that he's doing something
that I think really takes care of his
staff and his internal culture I think
it's interesting you know i am i here's
my this is actually not my general
thought this is my one thing i do well
in marketing is i don't think about what
it what i'm gonna do and then think
everybody's gonna do that it's been very
successful for me i try to think of the
general masses i have a vibe for that
it's not what I thought about twitter
mattering like social media what do they
know that my are know like if I wasn't
in the marketing and business world I
don't think I'd be really using it like
I never took pictures as a kid like
there's no why do you think I've no
throwbackthursday pictures there's no
frickin pictures of me in my life mom
and so that's a little inside joke of my
mom she made all mental pictures so so I
think that um I think that uh I think
that I personally am in a weird place
because I'm still gonna tip cash on top
of it's because it's just in me like I
was a stock boy that took out boxes and
people gave me tips and so ingrained in
me so even though I know I'm paying
twenty one percent more or whatever it
is I'm gonna probably put more cash just
because and then I'm scared if that's
gonna break the whole system because if
people still arbitrarily do that then
what did you do you just raised it 21
percent but I think the flexibility that
it allows organizations the way you can
take care of people that work for you
which will then in turn create better
service you know I also think that an
interesting model could have been just
raising the food prices in general I
think that's a fascinating thing about
the restaurant world you know the truth
is I really don't know I think that um I
wonder for people that are I think the
economy is very good right now I think
if tomorrow the Wall Street cats are up
to their no
and [ __ ] hits the fan are people gonna
be like well crap I don't want to go
there because I'm playing a 21% big and
maybe I'm in 10% tip mode right now well
how do you tip steve-o pretty much 20
just by default they rock really yeah I
double the first number in an ad light
on any kind of bill got it it's the fun
man
way to go honest yeah I mean but those
are big numbers right like those aren't
15 which is a lot of what people older
demo plays at 15 they kind of snuck up I
don't know I think it's a it's a it's a
very intriguing model it's forcing
something on the consumer which i think
is fascinating I think he has the brand
to get away with it for the people that
know I think a lot of people won't even
know why don't you realize they'll
realize when there's no line for a tip
and I'm curious how their reaction would
be that they got forced into a tip some
people get antsy when they're forced
into a tip for six or more so I don't
know I think it's very individual and I
think there'll be a lot of positive
definitely in the industry and there'll
be some negative from the end consumer
for me personally it's just gonna make
it more expensive for me to go to USB
places you know this guy you know those
places so because I'm going to still tab
what are your what are your thoughts
team I don't know I do you know about it
oh yeah
I don't know like I came up as an actor
so I know tons of people in the service
industries so like whatever ends up
screwing them the least is I think it's
a huge positive it's kind of a scary
situation to be forced to rely on what's
obviously a subjective judgement call
them just established I think the thing
that everybody's gonna worry about is
does the service change right like to
the people that hustle the most that's a
real challenge I think Danny will pull
it off operationally but I think fast
followers won't and then you're not
allowing the best servers to win which
eliminates meritocracy which then
creates lowest common courtesy and and
service I mean we don't have a tipping
story vaynermedia I get I don't have to
worry
you know I totally understand
I think that's easily handled because
you can just fire right like or you can
just give raises I mean there's a lot of
people always deploy that what we don't
have tipping and a hard thing sure you
have other ways to like you know there's
levers in all games right I think when
look I mean this is this gets into a
unionized conversation I was born in the
Soviet Union we've seen that play out at
scale it's really hard to suppress you
know humans and so but I but truth is on
a micro level on a Danny Meyer's
establishment's level I have enormous
confidence that he can do it I very much
feel that I could do very rogue [ __ ] at
Vayner because it's only 600 people it's
only a thousand people and whatever it's
gonna be that I could pull those levers
at super scales when it gets interesting
Dana hi my name is Dana geyser I work
for lover' imports in New York and I am
a Master Sommelier hopeful I wanted to
know your opinion on the future of
Master Sommelier and in reference to the
proliferation of social media bloggers
powerful wine critics etc great question
Dana Dan I think you know much of what's
going on in this episode things have
their moments and right now because of
the movie and because of this show
coming out like people are paying more
attention to Psalms and I think you'll
have more people get into the game we
have way more I run the Psalms and
people that are aspiring to be master
Psalms all the time because a lot of
them started watching Wine Library TV
when they were in high school or college
which makes me feel very old getting on
the 10-year anniversary of the show in
February which is insane and so I think
that um I think there's gonna be a
moment here for the next 36 to 60 months
that it's gonna be cool and respected
more I mean look if you were a chef in
the 1970s or 80s
you were the help in America now you're
celebrity so I think there's gonna be I
think this would be an amazing
opportunity I think the the bloggers and
the social media things and things that
things are just gonna amplify the
awareness of Psalms I think Psalms have
a lot of opportunity to review wines one
thing I want to do when I leave in the
comments going to this I want to start
sending Psalms wines from Wine Library
and have them review on the hundred
point scale and using those I think
their opinions matter quite a bit so I'm
looking for more democracy
stationed at Wine Library on shelf
talkers not just Parker Spectator you
know Colonia or me
I want like some of XYZ establishments
so I think that's one thing that I think
you'll see more of so I think there's
gonna be a nice half decade here of more
money for you guys and gals for events
and private tastings and you know the
when I was doing Wine Library and I was
doing private tastings for people I was
the help like I was a retail store owner
that would come to your house and I
would pour I'm a bartender right and yes
I gave my thoughts a little bit when I
became a wine library TV Gary people
paid me $5,000 to come to their house
and be the star it was just a little bit
of a shift of exposure and repositioning
no different than Bobby Flay compared to
the best chef in 1970 in New York City
help versus celebrity I think master
Psalms are about to go through a really
nice half decade Jane
[Music]
[Music]
kind of similar to the last question
kind of similar to the last question Jay
and I'll just you know it is what it is
the serendipity of it I I think it's a I
think it's a good and a bad thing I
think it comes down to Eugene and all
the other people with with greater power
and leverage money and exposure I do not
believe that money and fame change
anybody I think it just exposes who that
person actually is so do I think more
exposure around you Jane and all the
other your castmates on this show is
good better and different for the end
consumer I think it comes down to you
guys so Jane you might be awesome about
it right you may have a bunch of young
people 16 year-olds in New York going to
the kind of place that you work at you
know may ask you a question and look up
to you and say I want to be like you one
day and you could be encouraging or you
could be a jerk about it right like like
it's like it's just how you play this
newfound exposure Fame leverage people
looking at you differently and so if you
say that oh my god now I'm important and
you become more douchey like that has
happened in so many industries art music
wine food well then that's bad for the
consumer because now we're suppressing
people if you take your your found
leverage and you encourage people and
and you use it to teach them about
different wines and you get people to
start drinking she known from the Loire
Valley like my agenda was or Portuguese
wines or all this amazing thing well
then you're doing a great thing for the
consumer because the more different
kinds of wines they taste the more
they're gonna appreciate this incredible
thing that we're all passionate about so
I think it comes down to the individual
Psalm and so there's six right so right
so two of you may be incredible about it
three of you might be average about it
one of you may be a jerk about it and
that's what the net score is for the end
consumer
so Gary we need to know what wine will
Henrik Lundqvist drink from the Stanley
Cup when the Rangers won it this year
and will I be on hand to provide proper
service that's an amazing question when
Jimmy Josh great question brother 1994
Rangers winning the Cup is one of the
great days of my life it was my first
professional championship so but once my
team's when I stopped caring but I do
have an amazing place but in my heart I
hate
being a bandwagon fair but I always
watch arrangers in the last couple years
making their late runs in the season
good to see your massively passion fan
clearly this was a fun way to end it
two things no my prediction is my
prediction is you will not be on hand
because there'll be an emergency in your
business and you know the somme life and
you'll have to be there so you're gonna
miss it
sorry about that and I think Henrik is
gonna go with Brazilian sparkling wine I
know that's a left-field kind of thing
but I'm very bullish on the Brazilian
sparkling wine phenomenon I also find
Henrik extremely attractive which is
Henrik married can somebody check I
don't think he is right can you google
that real quick before I get myself in
trouble here but but but I can I can
punchline this last answer is because I
think if Henrik is single
I find myself believing that he's
spending time in Brazil and having fun
where he discovered Brazilian sparkling
wine and and that is why is he is
drinking it from the cup you would have
been there you were supposed to be there
he's married cool so the different
rationale to why he discovered him his
dear friends who are brazilians
introduced the sparkling wine to him and
and that's why he's gonna do it the
reason I wanted to say that is I really
do believe Brazilian sparkling wine over
the next 20-30 years there's a very
interesting category that nobody's
talking about in the wine world so 160
mixing the two worlds as a matter of
fact I've noticed a lot of people asking
for the question of the day so I'm
bringing you back that's right I'm
bringing it back and my question of the
day is what is your current favorite
wine good way it's almost like a prompt
at the walking library questions you
keep asking questions we'll keep
answering them
[Music]